That's the whole compiler.
I want to show you just a little bit of the possibility of doing some compiler optimizations.
Notice this sort of barrier here where we introduce lambda, where we introduce a function.
Remember I said that there's two parts to a compiler.
There's the part where we're first defining a language.
When we call lit and give it a string,
then we're doing some work to build up this function that's going to do the work
every time we call it again.
Anything that's on the right of the lambda is stuff that gets done every time.
Anything that's to the left is stuff that gets done only once.
Notice that there is a part here building up this set of s that I'm doing every time,
but that's wasteful because s doesn't depend on the input.
S is always going to be the same.
I can pull this out and do it at compile time rather than do it every time we call the resulting function.
I'll make this setofs and I'll give that a name--setofs.
Over here I'll do setofs equals that value.
It looks like I'd better break this up into multiple lines.
Now I pulled out that precomputation so it only gets done once rather than gets done every time.
You could look around for other places to do that.
I could pull out the computation of this set of characters
and do that only once as well.
That's a lifting operation that stops us from repeating over and over again
what we only need to do once.
That's one of the advantages of having a compiler in the loop.
There is a place to do something once rather than to have to repeat it every time.